so today imma be trying a little bit of
tactics frenzy five minutes should be
enough to break the record that is 23:19
that's the highest rating anybody's
achieved on tactic frenzy without
further ado here we go this one I like
rook check take the pawn escape with the
King well a bunch of moves here Wow oh
this is a nice one Jack Jack Jack and
Bishop c3 that was a very good exercise
mating 1 lovely I love making once and
now we've got ourselves a bit of a
smothered mates it's very nice this is
another method one no the pawns are
where the fonts moving yeah the pots
must be moving this way so there's no
mate in one so confusing
so King G 1 and I 2 tunics no defense
very nice very nice indeed mating 3
lovely and how about this one
g6 exposing the Queen and they will win
it so this looks like the end of a vase
study now we just need to know to find
out how to expose the Queen and win it
I think Queen d5 must be the first move
and then what
this is not easy ah 23 and the zoo song
right yeah exactly
Queen I won and there we exposed too
quick nice night as five takes attacking
two pieces of one's running away with
the bishop and will win a piece good
stuff so what's this one
rockin b2 is hanging in case we get but
we cannot get Queen to g5 immediately
whereas the solution is it as brutal as
this I think it actually is why why
didn't that work a little bit ship g6
first wow that is way too hard
it's these non sourcing solutions are
pretty hard to grasp trapping the Queen
nice wow this is a famous game as far as
I I can remember so we gotta go f4 check
no it's not if six first this is
starting to go off the rails now
okay this one is nice so Queen c7 hammer
blow hammer is not here but anyway and
this is a nice little mate pushy tt1
Queen to be five these are the good ones
these are the tactics that you see
immediately I like those
so the question is is rook h2 mates and
yes it is with a little bit of subtlety
queen f2 instead of green t3 immediately
that is mates okay we gotta take the
rook King be one so there is nothing
immediate kuru k7 looks normal
then check route p7 what's the solution
rooks e7 that Queen b6 key minutes
knocking see it not King it okay
like to win take the rook and take the
pawn and take the Queen okay here we go
King a six the king hides and mates
black to defend
where the pumps running opponents going
this way okay so confusing
kingi for king e5 we just run that was a
great exercise okay gotta go
Oh Brooke hitch one nice night it's 6:00
and we're done
Oh Queen 8h it wasn't even writer who's
rook the egg first
alright so I wasn't even close only
about 2,000 racing well fortunately I'm
better at tournament tests but I got to
work on this stuff